Few mental afflictions are as humbling or
as terrifying as what is known as ‘Pure’
OCD or, more colloquially, Intrusive Thoughts.
In standard Obsessive Compulsive Disorder,
a person is haunted by a worry that compels
them to repeat an often counterproductive
or fruitless action with manic intensity:
handwashing, turning off gas pipes, checking
their pulse and so on. But in ‘pure’ OCD,
there is no outward, physical action; the
problem unfolds – hence the name – purely
in the mind, yet it is, if anything, an even
more distressing condition. Image result for
Frank auerbach The Pure OCD sufferer is tortured
by thoughts that they want to do, or have
done, some of the most censored and abhorred
acts in our societies, acts that they themselves
despise and fear at an intellectual level.
They grow convinced of their wish, for example,
to murder a loved one, harm a child sexually
or assault a stranger. They cannot shut out
the idea that they may become, or have already
shown signs that they are, a psychopath, a
rapist or a paedophile. They scan their minds
ceaselessly, looking for evidence to confirm
their dreadful apprehension. So burdened are
they by these thoughts, they may not be able
to go anywhere near children or may take fright
at the sight of a knife in a drawer. Left
alone with a colleague, they may panic that
they could lose control and lunge inappropriately
at them. At the station, they are flooded
with anxiety at the feeling that they may
push their partner or their child under a
train. Having to think of oneself in these
terms quickly drains life of any of its pleasure.
The Pure OCD sufferer wakes up every morning
certain that they are one of the worst people
ever to have walked on the planet. There is
not, as yet, a foolproof way of treating the
condition – but discussions of how to approach
it reveal large differences in assessments
of how the mind operates. Psychiatrists tend
to prescribe antidepressants, in order to
lift the general mood of sufferers and thereby
lessen the tendency to ruminate to the point
of exhaustion. CBT psychologists will try
to argue closely with the intrusive thoughts,
so that eventually sufferers can logically
acknowledge that they truly have no intention
of harming anyone or doing anything obscene.
But it is psychotherapists
who have what is perhaps the most imaginative
and unexpected solution. They do not target
the thoughts themselves or argue with them
directly. They don’t try to reassure people
logically that they are not about to murder
a loved one or harm a child – because they
don’t believe that this is what is actually
at stake and judge that offering reassurance
on these points only legitimates a pattern
of thinking that has no basis in reality.
They locate the origin of the problem somewhere
quite different: the sufferer of pure OCD
has, first and foremost, a problem with self-esteem
and shame. The unfortunate person feels, at
some level, utterly disgusting and beyond
the pale – and will in the background have
been feeling like this for a long time. Somewhere
in their past, normally as a result of very
traumatic and degrading childhood relationships,
they will have derived an impression that
they did not deserve to exist. Their current
thoughts are not plans for the future, they
are attempts by the mind to find a match between
their basic sense of self and what would be
needed by their society to concur with it.
They are a move to bring about a form of dreadful
inner equilibrium, ensuring that the judgement
of the world falls in line with the judgement
of the self. Cases of Pure OCD are sometimes
diagnosed just after sufferers have achieved
something rather positive in the eyes of others:
they have been promoted or begun a fulfilling
relationship or mastered a project. It should
be a cause for celebration but happiness simply
feels unwarranted. By latching onto thoughts
of complete illegality, one is assured that
one’s self-esteem will remain at rock bottom.
Interestingly, in societies that find religious
transgression particularly abhorrent, Pure
OCD sufferers will be haunted by feelings
that they have offended God and are about
to be outed as sinners. Behind Pure OCD is
a person’s needs to find a reason to feel
awful, it isn’t about this or that condemned
act – and as the definition of awful changes,
so too will the manifest content of the intrusive
thoughts. The disease is anchored in self-loathing,
not in blasphemy, incipient paedophilia or
murderous intent.This analysis opens the way
to treatment. What the sufferer of pure OCD
needs, above all else, is to begin to repair
their self-loathing and shame. They need to
learn, through repeated encounters with an
outsider who casts a generous and sympathetic
eye on them, that they are not the worthless
being they take themselves for. Their problem
began with a deficit of love – and needs
to be healed by a loving act of witnessing.
Pure OCD thoughts are not wishes, they are
symptoms of radical self-distrust – and
these will start to lift once the afflicted
learn that most vital of arts: being a friend
to oneself. Our book what is psychotherapy
tells us exactly what going through therapy
is like and why it is so important.